[Music]
Rihanna Kelly Clarkson naked Markel
Hollywood's health beauty and fashion
tips reveals yes and let's start with a
style of the Royal kind Megan Merkel is
redefining duchess fashion at every turn
and it's come at a very hefty price to
$1,000,000 and it all started the day
she became Prince Harry's fiance
it cost a pretty penny to stay royal
ready and according to royal experts
Megan has spent more than a million
dollars on her style including dresses
coats and accessories since linking up
with Harry but if you think she's
getting glammed for free think again it
does fall now that she is married into
the royal family to the Prince of Wales
to cover the cost of her working royal
wardrobe the cost of her wedding
ensemble was over four hundred and forty
thousand dollars and her reception
outfit more than 157 thousand but maybe
that make them contributed but certainly
some of the cost for either of those
wedding dresses or Pat both of those
wedding dresses I believe was also
picked up by the palace Prince Charles
has been footing the bill for her
working wardrobe since the announcement
of his son's engagement so is the past
worth it I think most people would argue
that it is megan is now an ambassador
for the royal family look at the
publicity that she is brought in the
run-up to the wedding I'd argue that
it's worth every penny since becoming a
member of the royal family we've noticed
Megan wearing a lot of pink
I think it's Megan's way of choosing a
color but not wanting to upstage anyone
and it suits her the Duchess has also
ditched jeans and short dresses and is
now often seen wearing sheer tights so
far we haven't seen Megan recycle any
outfits like her sister-in-law Kate but
she did rewear these custom-made aqua
Zurich heels from her wedding reception
while attending the wedding of Harry's
cousin and Jude I'm quite sure that we
will see Megan step out in outfits that
she's worn before you know when you're
buying that sort of culture it would be
criminal to not rewear them
you